let's talk about all this with senior
political analyst brit hume good evening
brit
hi mike things are so polarized now even
independence day is controversial
well it seems to be and you know the one
thing that you never hear
critics of this country along the lines
we've just heard in anita's report
never hear them cite is some country
which measures up
to their standards you never hear about
another country which is doing a better
job of it than we had and there's a
reason for that
i can think of no nation on earth and
perhaps no nation in history
that has tried harder or done more to
bring its minority populations into the
mainstream of the country
with all its freedoms and advantages and
in fact you know
it hasn't been all that long ago that fr
that slavery
um which is talked about more today than
than at any time perhaps since the civil
war
um was universal it was everywhere going
back to biblical times it was everywhere
this country is is is gone a long way
uh longer i think than any nation to
remedy the ills that grew out of that
the
lack of freedom the severe violation of
human rights
you never hear these critics say well
we'd rather be like this country or that
country
they can't in my view what's striking to
me is this comes after we've had a
two-term
african-american president and now we
have an african-american
female vice president brit
that's one more sign of how open this
country has become and how much
more opportunity is available now to
minority populations than than ever used
to be the case
and that may be the case anywhere else
in the world so i i
my view is that the people who say these
things
they do a wonderful job of getting
publicity for themselves i mean this
group the squad
gets coverage far beyond its influence
but you know
you wonder if they if they have any real
historical knowledge if they remember
the civil war and what it was fought for
if they remember the civil rights
movement
and its great achievements in fact you
may have heard me say this before mike
but i think
among the greatest achievements of the
civil rights movement was the univ
virtually universal consensus
in this country among among all people
against racism
being called a racist labeled a racist
is one of the worst things that can
happen to you that's because the
american people
simply do not approve of racism they're
against it
and you know that's not true in every
other country but it's certainly true
here
these people you know you think they
were born 10 years ago do they not know
of these things do they know how
not know what it was like when we did
have systemic racism even after slavery
until the civil rights movement when
when laws and election procedures and so
forth were stacked against black people
all of that has been wiped away as a man
of faith britain makes you wonder what
it will take to heal this great country
at least with
those folks i think it'll take
a considerable leader i'm not sure we
have one yet
brit hume many thanks for your time
happy independence day
appreciate your analysis sir thanks mike
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else